Our first term right here only has one variable in it, x. And the power that x
is taken to is 4. So that means that the degree of this term is 4. This is a
fourth degree term. Now this next one is a little bit tricky. 100 is just a
constant term. It doesn't have any variable factors in it. Or in other words, it
has zero variable factors. So this means that it's degree is 0. This is true of
any constant term. If we had the number say, 78 here instead, or negative 432 or
19.3 any constant term, no matter what it's value is has degree 0. So that means
1/2 over here which is also a constant term has a degree of 0. So another way to
think of this is that if we desperately wanted to have a variable in a constant
term, we didn't want to change the value of the term, what power would that
variable need to be taken to? So let's say we have 1/2 here and we want an x in
that term. In order to keep this term equal to 1/2 we need to have x be to the 0
power since Any thing, any variable, any constant to the 0 power equals 1. That
means we would actually have 1/2 times 1, which is just equal to 1/2. But even
if we choose to write the term in this way with a variable involved the power of
that variable is 0. So this is still a 0 degree term For this next term y we
need to remember that any variable that doesn't have an exponent written
explicitly actually has an invisible 1. As its power. So this term has a degree
of 1. It's a first degree term. And lastly we have x squared, y squared, z
cubed.. So the degree of this term is just going to be 2 plus 2 plus 3, which is
equal to 7.